what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and a lot is happening
right now in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but a lot more is about to go
down we only have two episodes left of
secret Invasion and then we get Loki
season 2 which is going to deeply impact
the MCU as well as the Marvels which is
also going to be an extremely big Marvel
film and based off of some things that
we've heard recently this film might
actually be a lot bigger than we thought
it was going to be now there are a lot
of crazy rumors going around about what
could possibly happen in the Marvels and
they sound fantastic and it looks like
the next trailer for the Marvels is
about to come out relatively soon now
obviously the Marvels is going to tie in
directly with secret Invasion Nick Fury
is going to be heavily involved in the
Marvels and obviously he is the main
character of secret Invasion and in fact
if you noticed in the Marvel's trailer
Nick Fury actually looks like the old
Nick Fury he's wearing the eye patch
again he seems to be in better shape he
seems to be more him more of the old
Nick Fury so it looks like by the end of
secret Invasion the old Nick Fury is
going to be back however many people
have speculated that Captain Marvel
might be coming into the show secret
Invasion perhaps to fight the Super
Squirrel rabbit and this does make sense
however we have kind of learned a lesson
from Disney Plus shows these Marvel
Disney Plus shows tend to stay focused
on their main characters like in one
division nobody showed up there was no
crazy big Cameo yes Paul Bettany did
tease Us by stating that he was working
with somebody he's always wanted to work
with before but that turned out to be
himself but the focus date on Wanda and
the main villain Agatha nobody else
showed up really so we're gonna assume
the same thing is going to happen with
secret Invasion Nick Fury is going to
save the day along with the help of Gaia
who is also now a super scroll plus not
to mention the director of the show Ali
selum did say not to expect any cameos
and he recently said this so as of right
now we're not expecting Captain Marvel
to come in and save the day however
Captain Marvel is linked to secret
invasion and the new official full
trailer for the Marvels is confirmed to
be listed which means it is coming out
soon now this is probably going to come
after the finale of secret Invasion
again since secret Invasion goes right
into the Marvels there's going to be a
little bit of story overlap here so the
First full trailer we've gotten the
teaser but the full trailer should be
coming towards the finale of secret
Invasion so we can probably expect this
full trailer to come in about two weeks
and here we'll learn a lot more about
what the Marvels is really going to be
about now recently there's been a lot of
talk about some possible big spoilers
for the marbles talking about some
pretty big cameos and possible MCU
debuts that could take place in the
Marvel's film three of which have fans
really really excited and in interviews
people have been asking Brie Larson
about what's gonna happen and Brie
Larson Captain Marvel herself has been
playing pretty Coy but she does say that
the film needs to come out soon because
she can't keep this Secrets any longer
implying that there are some decent
secrets in the film that we're going to
see in a recent interview at the tjh
superhero car show and Comic-Con she was
asked to kind of give some spoilers
about the movie in which she said this I
sure can tell you that it is a film and
I can tell you that those people that
you've seen that you've talked about
they are in it and it will come out the
interviewer asked this year and she
responded with yes thank goodness
because I can't keep these secrets any
longer people we've got to get this
movie out the interviewer responded with
it's gonna be in theaters and Brie
Larson said it sure will be in theaters
and I would just hate to spoil any of it
you know it would just be so wrong so
people are fishing for these spoilers
but Brie Larson basically is stating
yeah there's secrets in the film but I'm
not spoiling it for you so let's talk
about what these secrets could be and
what the rumors are a big and really
exciting rumor is that Nova will be
making his MCU debut in the marbles now
we know that the Marvels is going to be
a Intergalactic film it's a big Cosmic
movie and we know that Captain Marvel
herself and really the Marvels her
Kamala Khan and Monica Rambo are going
to be exploring a lot of other planets
we've seen a couple of these already in
the teaser trailer and we've already met
a few new characters in The teaser
trailer so in the movie it wouldn't be
crazy for them to go to a planet
somewhere in the cosmos where Nova is at
now Nova was set up big time in Avengers
Infinity war and really he's kind of
been teased since we were introduced to
the Nova court and the first Guardians
of the Galaxy movie Thanos decimated
xandar we found that out in Avengers
Infinity war and this could mean that
there could be only one Survivor or
perhaps if there are no survivors the
Nova Force went into possibly Richard
Ryder or perhaps they've had Nova the
entire time because of course we know
that the MCU loves to do fresh takes on
some characters but Nova if he is going
to be a cosmic character in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which he should and
possibly even go on to join or lead the
new guard Guardians of the Galaxy team
then there is definitely a chance that
Captain Marvel and the others could run
into Nova at some point in time during
the Marvel's film and I would personally
love to see that and another thing I
love is bird dogs and thank you to bird
dogs for sponsoring this video If you
struggle with finding good shorts to
wear ones that actually fit and actually
look good the struggle is over bird dogs
make you look good and they are
extremely comfortable bird dogs are
specifically designed to look slimmer on
the thigh and the leg giving you a
sculpted look and the best part is they
are stretch khaki shorts they do the
exact same thing as Lululemon but they
fit way better most shorts out there
don't fit very well they're pretty
restricting they're stiff but cotton
they use is pretty terrible but bird
dog's fixes this issue by inventing
Cloud knit fabric that looks just like
khaki but stretches so you get a way
Slimmer fit without having to sacrifice
movement they also use anti-stink sweat
weakening fabric that helps keep you
cool and dry all day long I've
personally really struggled with shorts
because I'm not a tall guy and I'm kind
of bulky and I have not been able to
find shorts that aren't too long that
actually allow me to move but now I have
with bird dogs they are awesome and the
best part is if you order a pair you get
a free Yeti style tumbler so go to
birddogs.com Cosmic for a free Yeti
style tumbler with your order that's
style tumbler you won't want to take
your bird dogs off we promise you so
Nova is a big one but another really big
one is the Watcher thecosmiccircus.com
has exclusively reported that the
Watcher is going to be making a live
action MCU debut this year it did not
state what specific movie or show The
Watcher could be appearing in but we
really only have two kind of three
options Loki the marbles and Echo I
don't think the Watcher is going to be
popping up an echo the stakes for the
echo series just really don't seem to be
there I can't really see that having a
multiversal or or Cosmic threat in that
show so it comes down to Loki and the
Marvels and The Watcher could honestly
show up in either of these however the
Marvels is more of a cosmic space
adventure that could fit The Watcher
really well he could be out there in the
cosmos somewhere just monitoring the
events that are happening all over the
universe and right now we don't actually
know if there are certain Watchers for
certain universes because Marvel
definitely does things differently than
the comics in fact we saw Stan Lee's
cameo in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2
speak with three Watchers so they
already exist in our main MCU timeline
the only question is is there a watcher
for each Universe because if that is the
case then that definitely means that
it's more likely we see the Watcher in
the Marvels than in Loki however we are
not sure at this time but hopefully he
does make his debut in Loki or the
Marvels and the last one that is rumored
is Galactus now this is huge and again
this is just a rumor at this point it's
not confirmed by any means but again
since this is a cosmic film it would
make sense it would line up story was
for them to happen upon Galactus
somewhere in the universe in fact some
people are theorizing that the home of
the scroll scrollos wasn't exactly
killed by the cree but was actually
destroyed by Galactus now of course in
secret invasion they say the Creer what
drove them out but you do really never
know what the MCU there's a lot of
twists turns and Mr X now if Galactus
does make his MCU debut in the Marvels
it probably won't have much to do with
the actual story of the Marvels but will
most likely set something up for the
future probably the Fantastic Four since
the Insiders say right now that Galactus
is going to be the villain of the
Fantastic Four film and if they want to
tease Galactus beforehand before the
Fantastic Four film well the Marvel
seems like the movie to do it due to all
of the space traveling that they're
going to be doing traveling to multiple
parts of the universe and we do know
marvel is going to bring Galactus in at
some point in time so he's out there
somewhere and someone is bound to run
into him at some point in time it could
be the marbles and Marvel Studios has
already brought in Cosmic entities they
brought in the celestials and the
eternals so they have prepped us for the
arrival of Galactus could his first
appearance be in the Marvels we'll have
to wait and see on that and we'll have
to wait and see what the official
trailer shows us so hopefully only a
couple of more weeks to wait for that as
well but in the meantime let us know
your best theories about how these
cameos could appear in the Marvels down
below also don't forget to subscribe and
leave a comment this enters you in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month you can also further
support us on patreon you can check out
our website and our Discord server as
well and you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof
thank you